for the love of God what are they
breathing good morning Hank it's Tuesday
so I'm currently training for a half
marathon and a couple days ago I ran 12
miles in a row without stopping I'm not
gonna lie I'm extremely pleased myself
but the point here is that when I am
running I only have one pace which is
the fastest I can go sustainably like if
I were running from a fast a zombie I
could run faster than my running pace
but only for a few hundred yards and
then I would stop realize that my zombie
apocolypse strategy is always to run
face first into the horde of zombies so
that I don't have to be like the last
person on earth and I would give up
which is not really relevant to the
point here the point here is that my
running pace used to be about 10 minutes
5 seconds per mile now it's about 9:40 I
guess I should define what a mile is for
people who live outside the United
States so in distance terms
I believe 1 mile is equal to 22
kilowatts eventually I am going to
actually tell this story so I was
running and I wasn't feeling awesome and
somebody ran past me on the trail and
they gave me a thumbs up and I was like
oh god I hate strangers interacting with
me and there's something vaguely
condescending about a really fit runner
giving a SMO like me a thumbs up one of
the main reasons I like running is that
I'm by myself and I don't have to
interact with people but after I got the
thumbs up a super weird thing happened
which is that I started to be able to
run faster you can actually see this
happen on my running app you can see the
mile where I received the thumbs up I
receive a thumbs up and then something
physiological happened to me that
allowed me to run faster and also just
run more happily like suddenly I started
noticing the trees and thinking puts a
beautiful day out here what a planet
Earth is Earth really is by far the most
underrated planet so anyway I was
running along and after a while post
thumbs up I started to feel kind of
tired again and then I noticed that
someone was running toward me on the
trail and I thought do I do it do I dare
disturb the universe and then as they
got close mostly just to find out if it
would work I went with the thumbs up and
even though I did not get thumbed back I
felt the same surge of energy and
happiness and I started running faster
so the next person that came by I was
like and it continued to work now of
course part of me was like you have to
stop this this is humiliating you can't
throw out thumbs ups everywhere you go
you'll become known as the thumbs up guy
but then another part of me was like I
just ran the fastest mile of my entire
life
get a thumbs up you get a thumbs up
everybody gets thumbs ups this one we
ended off screen but it's still there
it kept working I have no physiological
explanation for this except that it
works it should tire me out thumbs and
up while I'm running but it doesn't it
just makes me feel great
I absolutely floated through that run I
mean until about mile 10 then I started
to feel terrible so friends if you see
me on the trails or you see me at a race
don't say anything just shoot me a
thumbs up I absolutely guarantee you
that I will return the favor okay I have
to go for my last training run now I
will see you on Friday